time now for morning rounds our look at
the medical news of the week beginning
with another reason to safely dispose of
expired and unwanted prescription drugs
the Food and Drug Administration says
that many people who begin to misuse
medications like opioids often get their
first dose by using drugs prescribed to
other people
today is prescription drug take-back day
organized by the DEA and state and local
partners the last time the event took
place was in October when Americans
turned in 366 tons of prescription drugs
at almost 5200 sites across the country
CBS News chief medical correspondent dr.
Jon LaPook and CBS News contributor dr.
Tara Narula are here to tell us more
about the concern with us we all have
this stuff in you know in our bathroom
cabinets why is it so important to turn
this stuff in when you think about the
span of how big this problem is almost
six and a half million Americans are
affected by prescription drug abuse and
we really have an epidemic in this
country of addiction overdose and death
in particular from opioids you know drug
overdose is now the leading cause of
injury-related death overtaking motor
vehicle accidents or firearms the
majority as you mentioned of people who
abuse prescription drugs are getting
them from friends and family so how is
that happening well drugs that are left
in the medicine cabinet
in drawers in the kitchen on the shelves
or are thrown away inappropriately this
is a breeding ground for abuse for meds
that can be stolen sold or for children
to get their hands on medication so in
the last 12 years through this program
they've been able to collect almost 7
million pounds of drugs so this is
really a great first step so this is a
particularly good time of the ER to be
addressing this but where can people
turn in their medications the rest of
the year right what's kind of cool on
our website you'll see a link to a
website there are these tools and you
put in your zip code and up pops a bunch
of pharmacies that are near you mostly
pharmacies and you can go over there and
then they can safely dispose of whatever
it is that you have now they say
specifically that if there is no such
collection place near you or if there
aren't specific instructions on the
bottle then the FDA has this handy-dandy
instruction guide they say follow these
simple steps 1 mix so mix the medicines
crush the tablets or the capsules and
mix it with an unpalatable substance
like dirt or kitty litter then place
them in a container such as a sealed
plastic bag throw it in your household
trash and then very important scratch
out any kind of identifiable information
so that nobody else can take that and
then if it's empty toss it out a lot of
these locations Terra are not places you
would think would have a service like
this yeah so one of the places as John
mentioned that's really safe and not
intimidating is at the corner of happy
and healthy Walgreens this is really one
of the first it's not a Walgreens
commercial no it is what it is what it
is this is one of really the first
retailers that's rolled out a national
effort in the past year to deal with
this epidemic and they have kiosks in
the pharmacy area that are open during
pharmacy hours where you can come in
drop off your bottles they've been able
to collect the equivalent of 40 midsize
cars what that would weigh in just one
year Wow so clean out your medicine
cabinet and you'll have so much more on
their news okay all right our next topic
one of the most devastating global
diseases malaria this past Tuesday was
World Malaria day meant to focus
attention to the mosquito-borne disease
while malaria was eliminated from the
u.s. in the early 1950s it remains
widespread and deadly across the globe
with the majority of cases reported in
Africa according to statistics from the
World Health Organization in 2015 there
were 212 million new malaria cases
reported resulting in an estimated 429
thousand deaths okay so John what kind
of progress has been made on malaria in
the last decade there actually has been
huge progress so between 2010 and 2015
the new cases fell by 21% and death
rates fell by 29% but still you look at
these statistics we're not doing well
enough and the goal is by 2030 to have
all of that fall by 90%
antara there's still a surprising number
of cases in the u.s. there is and it's
something that's really off our radar
screen but it is a public health problem
in this country that accounts for
morbidity and mortality now most of this
is travel related so it's people
traveling and returning with malaria
foreign visitors or immigrants and it
really is something that's preventable
with pre travel consultation so you can
get
anti-malaria drugs you can take
precautions against mosquitos and if you
have prompt and quick diagnosis a
problem that's can be avoided but when
you look at the numbers it is sort of
staggering when they looked between 2000
and 2014 there were about twenty-two
thousand hospitals ations for malaria
which is about 1500 per year 22% were
severe cases and about a hundred and
eighty deaths and in general this is
very costly to us as well so for four
days of hospitalization the cost of
treating someone with malaria around
$25,000 so John with globalization and
climate change mosquito-borne illnesses
are almost here to stay in some knives
of some scientists is there hope of
eradicating malaria from the planet at
any point boy wouldn't that be great you
know there there are a bunch of
different ways of going after it but the
most exciting thing are is this vaccine
so the w-h-o announced just this past
week that probably next year they're
probably going to try in the trial in
three places in Africa the first
approved malaria vaccine now I spoke a
couple years ago to Munsif Slough a
who's the head of R&D for
GlaxoSmithKline he had spent 27 years of
his life at that point now it's 29
trying to develop this vaccine the Gates
Foundation will Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation also involved other people
and it's 30 to 35 percent effective you
say well that's not that great yeah but
when a lot about how many hundreds of
thousands of people died here I'm very
excited about that I want to be there
when that first vaccine is good I like
to you can end the malaria segment on a
high note yeah
dr. Jon LaPook and Tara Narula thanks
for your time